hi everyone and welcome to Intelligence
Squared I'm Josh glancy special
correspondent for the Sunday Times
um we are recording on Monday October
the 10th from a studio well it's really
a sort of bar to be honest in central
London and I'm very excited to introduce
our guests Orlando 5g's
um
obviously a very uh well-known uh writer
on all things to do with Russia
um he's an award-winning historian he's
a teacher at birkbeck College University
of London Trinity College Cambridge I'm
sure other places over the years as well
um he's the best-selling author of nine
books on Russian and European history
including Natasha's dance and a people's
tragedy and his new book which you can
see here uh we will be discussing today
and it's called the story of Russia it's
obviously extremely timely
um and I think Orlando is fair to say
was written somewhat with current events
in mind when did you start writing this
book well it was my lockdown book so I
delivered it in November of last year
and then hurriedly you know as we
altered the publication date
uh rewrote the last chapter at greater
length
um and the cutoff point was the 20th of
April
um but you're right that it it was in a
way a response to the worsening
situation as I saw it from the beginning
of the invasion which let's not forget
was 2014 yes
and my sense that the way the Russians
saw their history and the way in which
the regime was mobilizing that history
for its purposes was so very different
from the way we saw Russian history
certainly the way I had taught Russian
history for 35 years that we needed a
book that would
be not just a sort of concise history of
Russia over a thousand years which I
hope is it is an enjoyable read but uh a
book that would look at the sort of
driving ideas of Russian history and the
mythologies about the past that have
been used by rulers
um over the centuries to legitimize what
what actions they take and project a
future for Russia so I felt that there
was a need for that because of this
growing you know dissonance really
disconnect between how we see Russia and
how the Russians see their own history
and so you're writing you you've you've
finished this book and then obviously
events they don't overtake it in fact
they're quite the opposite they make it
sort of more more pressing
um and you're right to point out this
conflict didn't exactly start in
February 2022 in fact it it really
probably started in 2014 but but how
surprised were you by the way in which
events came to pass at the beginning of
this year lots of people were quite
taken aback
others said right you know no we said
Putin was like this all along were you
quite shocked by what happened in
February
yes I mean I was shocked by the scale of
the invasion by the
um yeah the the the Blitzkrieg on Crete
are on Kiev and the and the general all
front attacks surprised me I but I had
been aware as I think most people were
that there was a growing likelihood of
of the conflict over NATO expansion
whatever it is that triggered the
invasion
um for in Putin's head
um and
um so I I think it was a partly a
response to that sense that we needed to
unpack the ideas that Putin had about
Russian history
um I think that the
um immediate sort of sense that I had
that this was was coming was was was
that uh now Infamous essay he wrote in
July 2021 on the so-called historical
Unity of Russians and ukrainians which
did strike me as as a sort of uh but now
we see it as a justification for the war
but it it did really like a declaration
of war at the time if that's how he
genuinely felt then
um and that's that that was something he
felt strongly enough to spend his
lockdown months studying very badly
Russian history
um so you were both during lockdown
beavering away on your Russian history
is slightly better than he does in some
ways but but
um he he he there's nothing wrong with
that essay factually it's just it's a
very weird interpretation to make and
it's completely irrelevant because
actually you know Ukraine has been a
fully independent sovereign state since
1991 and Russia accepted that for a very
long time so
um it was a very bizarre thing then for
the President of Russia to come out with
um and that did strike me as as ominous
but I wouldn't claim that I predicted
the invasion by any stretch no
um I think
given what's been happening the last few
days I think we should address some of
that
um and some of its historical Anderson
and antecedents and then and then maybe
sort of swing back a little deeper into
history
um we obviously all saw
the bridge uh the courage bridge to
Crimea uh partially destroyed by
explosions
um on Saturday today when we're
recording we've we've just seen Putin's
retaliation and it's not pretty
um so
I'm interested I mean Crimea is
some obviously something that matters
enormously to him it's a point of Pride
he's responded quickly and violently
with missile strikes across Ukrainian
cities why is Crimea so important why
does he feel his Prestige is bound up in
it and why did that bridge attack uh hit
him hard why did it hurt sure well uh
the the last part of your question is
easy enough to to answer in the sense
that it really was the prestige
accomplishment as he sees it of of his
regime to connect Russia back to Crimea
physically in a way that it hadn't been
previously although of course they had
the Naval Base
um uh that they rented so to speak
um but yes Crimea is absolutely crucial
my book starts in 2016 with the opening
of um this hideous kit nationalist
Monument to the Grand Prince of Vladimir
or volodemia as the UK ukrainians would
call him the ruler of late 10th Century
cave and ruse who converted for himself
and his people to Christianity and he
did so in the Crimea in a place called
her sonosis which is just outside
sevastopol
um and this uh for Putin was uh as he
said in that speech on the opening of
The Monument the big the foundation of
the modern Russian State
um the gram the patriarch kiril who was
very much behind this project as well
um argues that you know in taking on
Christianity for his people it it was
the found foundation of the the ruse or
Russian Civilization now of course for
the ukrainians this is absolutely
nonsense because they as they said at
the time have their own Monument albeit
built in 1853 on the Russian Empire and
they would see uh that entry into
Byzantium which effectively is what
happened with the conversion to
Christianity as the foundation of a
modern Ukrainian European state in other
words we elected to join Byzantium that
was our a window onto onto Europe so
there are two conflicting Foundation
myths here and in a sense you could root
the war to a tussle over whose
Foundation myth is is true I don't think
either is true actually I think the
truth about Kevin ruse is that it was a
multi-ethnic open step territory with
all sorts of people roaming across it
and ethnicity didn't really connect the
people of of of kievan ruse to anything
that one could trace to the modern day
but as Foundation myths they're terribly
important because they both root the
foundation of their Nations
to Crimea and for the Russians it's
particularly important because of that
Christian civilization that begins there
it's also important I think for Russia
in a more modern context because
it's you know a place where so many
people in the Soviet Union went on
holiday it's a great Resort it's a hot
it's the South it's the good life of
Summer it's also
um the seat of the Black Sea Fleet in
sevastopol so that's absolutely crucial
to have that for Russia that access to
the Black Sea and the ability to to
dominate the near East which they had
with uh sevastopol from from the late
18th century really
and um I'd say also it's terribly
important to Russia because
um it sort of connects Russia to to
Europe in itself in a way that it
couldn't really claim
other than through Crimea because
it's it's it's Crimea that made Russia a
blacks a Black Sea power gave it access
to the Mediterranean
um so it's it's really quite fundamental
to the Russian sense of their historic
Roots but also their European nurse
so for all those reasons I think it's a
sort of it's a red line for for for
Putin in his conception of the origins
of Russia in his conception of what
Russia is
um and so I think if if this war gets to
become a sort of
fight over Crimea itself as the as the
bombing of the of the bridge suggests it
might if it goes on from being simply a
you know an attack on the logistics of
the Russian army if it if the ukrainians
want to take back their borders to 1991
pre the 2014 Invasion and if NATO is
prepared to back them to that point I
think we're going to get into a very
dangerous area of escalation I wouldn't
be surprised if if it was a question say
of Ukrainian troops you're actually
marching into Crimea I think at that
point Putin would
probably resort to tactical nuclear
weapons if he's exhausted all the other
escalatory measures he can still take
because it it's an attack on Russian
soil it's it's an attack on Russian soil
but it's I mean yeah he's declared the
the annex territories Russian yeah but
it's more than that it's an attack on
the Russian Soul right yeah that's how
Putin would see it your your
descriptions are two foundational myths
the the features editor in in me is just
thinking sort of Vlad versus Vlad yeah I
I I I avoided that cliche well enough
for your history and I'm a journalist
but
um
the ukrainians obviously
want Crimea back I mean that they've
been quite explicit about that indeed uh
clearly we assumed that that attack was
by them and was an expression of that
desire
um what what does it mean to them how
important is is that is is Ukrainian
desire for Crimea a relatively new thing
because after 2014
there wasn't didn't seem like there was
that much of a move to actually
realistically take Crimea back certainly
not from the International Community uh
do they also feel that it is
foundational to to their identity an
identity that is still is evolving in
front of our eyes or
is is that quite a new thing that they
can't say yeah well I mean there wasn't
much effort after 2014 because the
Ukrainian Army was very weak the regime
was very weak and because the West
basically was very weak in its response
to the annexation
um since then there's been quite a bit
of NATO investment in Ukraine which is
part of the problem for Russia
um because they see NATO attending
Ukraine into a sort of anti-russia as we
can put it in the essay I referred to
but for I think for the ukrainians it's
a simple principled matter of this is
the territory that is ours this is our
territorial Integrity this is what has
been internationally recognized this is
what this is the security guarantees we
supposedly had in the Budapest
memorandum of 1994 it's all everything
about modern day Ukraine is based on the
borders of 1991 and so you your Crimea
is integral to that but
um I fear that it will be too late now
for the ukrainians to to get back Crimea
partly because the West has been so sort
of almost complicit really in in the
annexation I mean I was so I I mean I
felt very strongly at the time
um having a particular investment in
Crimea because I wrote a book on the
cranium war and uh had already by that
stage built connections with with
Crimean tartars and and and other people
in Crimea and felt very angry at the way
the West just sort of accepted it as a
fate I can't play
um but you know since 2014 Ukrainian
national identity has has strengthened
immensely
um you know Putin may say the ukrainians
are not a nation but you know boy has he
made them into one bite by by
invading them again and I think part of
that National Unity is an uncompromising
determination
to reclaim Crimea well
as I have already suggested I'm not sure
that's possible without nuclear war and
so at some point I fear there's going to
have to be
um a compromise and the West will
probably I suspect at some point have to
start leaning on the ukrainians to do
what nobody wants to see them to do but
um may become inevitable which is trade
land for peace
certainly not something they seem very
keen to do at the moment no I mean I
think in that way zelenski is in a bit
of a corner really because the
Nationalist element you know is now so
Universal in Ukraine I mean the
ukrainians I've spoken to the idea that
they might
sort of give recognition that Crimea is
now Russia or even dombas is now I mean
this is something no one I don't think
in Ukraine is prepared to accept
I mean having said that uh I think that
the occupied territories of donbass
contain a lot of people who I'm mainly
old because they've lived there all
their lives and they don't have mobility
and
they probably you know they say it's a
shame that half the City was destroyed
that they live in but they I don't think
they feel that strongly about it because
they just want to go on living their
daily lives and most of them are Russian
speakers so they're not politicized
about it in the way that younger
ukrainians are or the Ukrainian
nationalists are who completely
understandably want Crimean back
and so
take us a little bit back to the
beginning
why why does Ukraine play such a central
role in the foundation of Russia and and
we've talked about Crimea but Ukraine
more generally
um and why is it that someone like Putin
can
convincingly at least internally
convincingly claim that Ukraine is
Russia
um obviously a lot of people that speak
Russian so that's one reason but but
take us back to some of the history you
talk about this but what is the story
about Ukraine that Russia tells itself
the story that Putin tells the Russians
and it's the story that basically
Russian imperial historiography told the
Russians from the 18th century is that
Ukraine was little Russia Ukraine was
part of Greater Russia
um it has a dialect but not a language
um and it's uh Capital Kiev was the
foundation of modern Russia but that was
the first state
so
um it's a source of Russian civilization
for the Russians as well as a source of
their Christianity
um and although for much of Russia's
history after the fall of Kevin Roos in
1240 when the Mongol occupation
overturned Kiev and subjected most of
Russia and about half of present-day
Ukraine to Mongol rule indirect rule
basically they collected tribute yes
um and uh from that point in 1240 much
of Ukraine actually took a different
path from Russia I mean the western
territories uh were brought into the all
bit of Poland Lithuania which is one of
the great medieval States
um uh Catholic so that you have a number
of Catholics in Western Ukraine
um but from the 17th century Ukraine
um was brought back into the Russian
fold because of the Cossacks essentially
and the Cossacks were again again
they're not particularly Ukrainian or
particularly Russian they're sort of
multi-ethnic caste of of Warriors who
who carry out everything from brigandage
to fighting for anyone who pay them and
they had their own sort of meta sort of
quasi-states really uh hitmanates in in
the area we now call Ukraine so there
was a hepmann of uh of of Don Cossacks
and the parisia Cossacks and the
zaparesian cossex were fighting because
they were Orthodox against Poland
Lithuania and invited
um the Tsar to support them well that's
our Alexei at this point and we're
talking about the 1640s early 50s was
very reluctant to do that but
interestingly it was the patriarch Nikon
who wanted uh Russia to back this
Orthodox War fought by the Cossacks
against the poles in lithuanians right
as a sort of holy war so I mean I mean
this is quite you know resonant with
what's happening today I mean because a
major source behind this was
patriarchill who would also say that he
had said that the invasion of Ukraine is
a holy war
so it's from that point that the the
Ukraine is brought back into a Russian
fold and under Catherine the Great is
made a regular part of provincial
Administration
and she then leads the conquest of what
becomes known as New Russia which are
the areas that have just been annexed
minus the dombas so new Russia was all
of the coastal area on the North
uh on the Northern literal of the Black
Sea so for magiesa through to mariu pole
and and they were called new Russia
until 1917. so that becomes another
dispute about what is the place of
Ukraine in Russia's Legacy in in its
territorial claims because you know
under the Soviet Union it didn't really
matter so much where the boundaries were
I mean the I the idea at the Soviet
Union was that that nation-states were
gone that you could have a cultural
Nation but otherwise you were all part
of the same political entity which was
Soviet
so the breakup of the Soviet Union in
1991 then raised a whole set of new
issues about Ukraine because those
Southern areas of new Russia and the
dombas were claimed by Russian
nationalists like sojournitzen like
subject who was Putin's Mentor as
historic Russian lands and so in that
essay I referred back to from 2021 Putin
makes the argument there that if the
Ukraine wants wanted to leave the Soviet
Union as it voted to do so in 1991 then
um fine but it should leave with what it
came in with right and there are two
ways you can see that you could say it
came in with nothing because Ukraine
didn't really exist as a nation-state
although there were two moments but you
know very brief moments in the
revolution in the Civil War when there
were Ukrainian parliamentary and then
nationalist governments in situ but they
didn't last very long
or you could say they should have what
they had minus new Russia and the and
the donbass
so one way of looking at Putin's sort of
strategies to say he's trying to reclaim
those historic Russian lands but you
know he hasn't really made clear what
his War aims are or why he's fighting he
began with the whole question of it's a
historically Justified War because
Ukraine is is uh is us your brain is
just a variant of Russians and so should
belong to us
he's then moved on from that to argue
and this I think is is more
I think this is closer to his real
thinking
he argues in that essay that every time
Ukraine after the middle of the 17th
century and it was reincorporated into
the Russian World if you like
every time that the little Russians as
he would call them tried to break free
from the great Russians the Russians uh
to assert their independence they fell
under the influence of hostile Western
Powers so he cites the poles and the
lithuanians in the in the 18th century
the austrians in the 19th century the
Germans in the first world war the
Allied powers in the Russian Civil War
the Nazis in the second world war then
NATO today he would say they've all been
doing the same thing which is
encouraging Ukrainian nationalism to
turn Ukraine against Russia
and that has to come back to your
question rather long-winded why that has
real resonance with with many Russians
who've been brought up on this story of
Russia
taught in schools embedded in Russian
historiography and since then pumped out
through every propaganda Channel film TV
books novels and a whole lot
that um that Ukraine is that Russia is
is vulnerable to attack from the west
and and Ukraine is its most vulnerable
point and and the sense that the
ukrainians sort of can't really be
trusted to not be under the sort of
Aegis of Russia in some way yeah because
yeah I mean it's so it's not it's hard
to tell how Putin would actually explain
all of that because the implication of
his essay is and everything he's he's
argued is that they that they they have
a sort of illusory nationalism an
illusory sense of their nationhood which
has been all pumped up for them by by
enemies of Russia in the West
um and uh but on the other hand you know
you
there there are many other ways one
could explain them so it's not clear
exactly where he comes from on that yeah
so
Putin is obviously as as we've discussed
someone who thinks about history in his
own particular way
um but you write in your book that
history somehow matters more in Russia
almost than anywhere else
in the world which is obviously a
convenient thing for a historian of
Russia to say but but you know you do
make this point compellingly that
actually history
is very Central to the Russian
conception of itself
um I can think of some other places
where that's true as well but what why
do you think
history is so important to Russia and
why do you think it plays such a
dominant role in informing its Its
Behavior today and that obviously
extends well beyond Putin
actually takes the place of normal
political discourse
um there's very little tradition and
certainly under Putin there has been
very little
space for or even agreed even agreement
about what you know what terms like
democracy mean so I mean you know Putin
defines it as Sovereign democracy which
means we call it democracy and then you
have no right to tell us right what the
content of it should be I mean we have
elections we can fix them but there are
elections you fix your elections we're a
Democratic Society but we want to be
Sovereign and Define our democracy for
ourselves of course that's a very
different view of democracy from the way
uh we in the west as liberal Democrats
if you like would see it so the the
normal discourse and understanding of
political Concepts it just isn't
developed in Russia because of the
weakness of parliamentary traditions
because of the weakness of free speech
and assembly because of
the history of Russia under autocracy
for so many centuries so history for the
state
is a substitute for that because you can
outline what your ideology is by
referring to your interpretation of
History so Putin is is a very slavophile
Leader by which I mean that he defines
Russia's interests in opposition to the
West not just as different from the West
which is the original more benign
interpretation of the Slava files when
they were sort of basically
intellectuals worried about
um you know the westernization of the
Russian language or when they felt that
Russians were losing their sense of
national identity because they were
aping the the West
um Putin's slavophilism is rather more
radical than that I would put it in the
category of those late 19th century
slavophiles like Danny levsky who argued
in the wake of the Crimean War defeat in
in the middle of the 1850s the the the
West is is our enemy that we as Russians
need no longer measure our success by
Western standards and that we should
reject all Western so-called Universal
principles as just hypocritical as
double standards because they apply one
set of rules to us and then live by a
different set of rules that's what these
sort of Russian nationalists learn from
the Crimean War debacle and
um so I think Putin comes out of that
stable but that means that that radical
nationalist slavophilism then carries
with it and is indeed expressed through
a number of historical interpretations
and they have to be made clear in order
to delineate what is the ideology of
putinism so he he's opened all of these
my history parks where school kids
military cadets are all sort of taken by
the coach load to be told what they
should think about Alexander they should
think about Peter the Great or what they
should think about Russia's relations
with the west or what they should think
about the colonization of Siberia so you
know all of these things become part of
the ideology and then are activated to
carry out policy because they will fit
the national story that's how it works
and and and you know there's no other
way they can do that ideologically than
through history I believe that's
fascinating so it's sort of hit there
it's it's a sort of
it reminds me when I was in America
people often used to say during the
Trump era particularly that in America
politics and entertainment become merged
and you're saying in Russia's politics
and history
become merged in that way um
clearly you you know you you write and
and feel that the West has got quite a
lot wrong about Russia or misjudged
various things about Russia in recent
decades and maybe for longer than that
um
one of the things that you write a lot
about is is religion and it strikes me
that that's probably one of the things
that we we do sometimes misunderstand
about Russia what do you
what role is is is tell me a little bit
more about the role the Russian Orthodox
church and religion is playing in this
war
um and why do you think we we sort of
struggle perhaps to fully comprehend
that sometimes
what if I can take the second part first
uh um I think the reason why we have got
Russia wrong for so long in all sorts of
ways is that we've tended to firstly
impose our own Western
values onto Russia and then declare
Russians and the Russian nation and
state to be a failure because they don't
quite come up to our expectations
um and part of the reason for that I I
think and I argued in the book is that
the West has always been very dependent
on the Russian Intelligentsia but its
views of Russia those are the people
Scholars talk to those are the people we
read those are the people we feel and
Affinity with because most people who
study Russia or deal with Russia never
go beyond Petersburg and Moscow anyway
those are the people they're going to
meet the trouble with that is that the
Russian Intelligentsia sees Russia
through westernize
so you get this sort of uh Perfect
Circle you can't break
um
and and
the the church is a good example of of
those spaces of the Russian mind if we
can put it that way that might I don't
like using the words mindset and stuff
but you get into the Russian soul
for sure but I mean those areas that
have formed the Russian way of thinking
about the world that stem from its
religion tend to get overlooked by the
secular Russian intelligents here and by
those who rely on the secular Russian
intelligence here to look at Russia and
we we tend to think well you know
there's a division between church and
state but there isn't one really in in
Russia Russia has always been
politically
um a sort of Byzantine uh Empire in the
sense that as in Byzantium church and
state are two sides of the same plane
um that Tsar who inherits from Byzantium
the not just the blessing of Christ but
the power of a human God
so under the Russian tradition of
autocracy
um there's always been this tendency to
sacralize political power so the Tsar is
the holy tar
uh which you can see then feeds into the
cult of Stalin and Lenny and as these
almost sort of god-like figures that
have to be worshiped and venerated and
taken on trust never questioned
um
um the other part of that religious
concept of power
is is the notion of the Russian land or
holy Russia itself because this is part
of the original mythology of of Russia
that it is literally the place where
Christ is going to come when he
reappears um
you know it's a Russia has the true God
because
um
the it's basically what we call the
Third Rome I uh Third Rome ideology that
Moscow after the fall of Rome after the
fall of Constantinople in 1453 when it
was overrun by the Turks uh
was the last true seat of Orthodoxy
Christianity
and and the you know the the Catholic
state had had fallen into heresy
effectively so so that idea that you
know we have the True Religion and we
have uh the ruler who is the true God is
a very important part of that but it's
uh it's not just religion I think I
think it's also another element of this
which comes from the the Mongol
occupation the Mongols the golden horde
as they were in Russia occupied and
collected tribute from from the Russian
principalities for 250 years more or
less at the time when the rest of Europe
was going through the Renaissance the
Scientific Revolution codification of
the laws everything that we now see as
the foundations of Western Civilization
but they took place at the time when
Russia was basically paying tribute to
to the Mongols and never had the ability
to to to to develop or even have contact
with your very much so
um so so the the tradition that comes
out of that Mongol experience which I
think is always denied in Russia because
they like to see themselves as basically
Europeans and Christians and that the
Mongols came but they they left and
there was no trace of them this was
nonsense the Mongol occupation left deep
imprint on Russian culture and above all
on on Russia's statehood because uh Ivan
IV of the terrible who was the first
sort of tar of of Muscovy as it was then
to push back the the Mongols and build a
state around moscow's power
um did so by inheriting so many of those
Mongol political Traditions so the idea
that you know you own the land as singis
Khan thought he did and that your your
serviters may be rewarded with bits of
land for serving you but you can take it
away from them any moment there's no
full elodial property in the western
sense so there's no development in
Russia of a fully independent
land-owning aristocracy that their
military and civil serviters who's who's
whose tenure of land is conditional upon
the child's favor I would go so far as
to say that you can trace that right up
to Putin and the oligarchs that they are
like the boyas to Ivan IV that you know
they can be allowed to enrich themselves
yes but they have to to do what the Tsar
tells them if Putin tells them give me a
hundred million dollars or if Putin says
go and run trukotka as he said to
Abramovich they have to go and do it we
have a couple of questions I I want to
get to that quite from uh audience
members that they're quite big ones
though so we might have to sort of
you might have to sort of probably see
the answers a bit I have one quick
question for you before we get on to
them which I'm always curious about what
what has drawn you to Russia as a
historian as a writer
over the years that maybe there may be a
long answer to that but what what is the
sort of the thing that really has drawn
you to this subject this story this
country over the years well I mean
originally I was pushed in that
direction I mean when I was an
undergraduate I was interested in German
Jewish intellectual history right uh
particularly the young hegelians and my
my supervisor at that time was uh uh at
that point a very famous historian
called Norman Stone I don't know if you
ever came across him yeah I've read his
book and and and he said to me Orlando
if you got trouble with your girlfriend
or you hung over you don't want to
battle with Hegel every morning so why
did you do something empirical
and suggested Russian peasants and they
gave me a grant to to learn Russian uh
which I did in 1983 and 1984 went off to
to the Soviet Union to to work on
Russian peasants and the archives and I
think I just took to it really I mean it
I I love the quality of the intellectual
life there the Russians were never any
good at small talk you know I'm not
really good at the small talk either
um they're good at you know debates over
the kitchen table that's their sort of
world or at least it was in in 1984.
um and yeah it was just such a big big
culture and big history and uh yeah just
I just got hooked on on on that I
suppose I mean but yeah I have to say
it's always been a love-hate
relationship I mean the things about
Russia I just you know makes me want to
scream and particularly you know this
war obviously
um but the fascination as as never has
never dimmed even if I have to sort of
occasionally go and do something else
it's like like the book I write on
called the Europeans which was my relief
from it right yeah yeah so right a
couple of questions to finish
um Kyle in New York asked would liberal
democracy be wrong for Russia and I
think that's an interesting one because
there was this perhaps naive sense after
the fall of the Soviet Union that
actually democracy could work in Russia
and that as you alluded to earlier that
Russia would become like us
um
that obviously doesn't look very likely
at the moment uh one doesn't want to be
sort of overly generalized but is is
democracy is in the liberal sense we
understand it compatible with Russia a
few things well if you look through
Russian history there's many elements of
of social organization which should
intrinsically Democratic in spirit so
the basic unit of Russian Society until
uh collectivization in the 1930s was the
Russian peasant commune which was a
thoroughly Democratic egalitarian
self-governing community of prison
farmers
so it's not that there isn't the ability
to become Democrats but I don't think
the liberal Democratic mold would would
fit very easily uh for all the sorts of
reasons we've been discussing
but you know
um I have a I have a sense that in 1917
there could have been a different more
direct form of democracy run through the
Soviets now don't get frightened and
think I'm some sort of communist because
the Soviet all it means is is a
committee basically it's self-governing
committee and I think that there were
people at that time some of the
mensheviks and SRS or socialist
revolutionaries who who could see
um the the direct participatory
democracy of local Soviet power
could be somehow grafted on to
um a national parliamentary system of
democracy I I not a class-based one like
the Soviets but a generally National
representative body like the constituent
assembly which unfortunately was elected
and then the Bolsheviks closed it down
so you know there I don't think liberal
democracy is an easy fit on Russia um
and I don't think it ever will be
probably but I think that um that more
forms of direct democracy could work I
but I don't think that means and this is
perhaps the the the real
um sort of issue with what I've just
said I don't think you could move
towards some sort of regional governance
which people at hodokowsky favor which
people
um in the opposition favor because
Russia if you think about it is a state
with which is heavily
natural resource dependent so fossil
fuels minerals
Etc and if you're allow I mean so in
those economic resources sort of require
a highly centralized state in order then
to redistribute the income from
gas prom or whatever yeah I mean the
problem is it doesn't get redistributed
because there's so much corruption
um but it doesn't get redistributed to
everyone
it doesn't get yeah I mean it's the
patrimonial state yes that's exactly an
example of what I mean by the
patrimonial state uh and and the people
who who govern that Industries like
gazprom for Putin and the Russian State
they they see it as their their feeding
grounds they literally refer to it as
their feeding grounds which is an old
patrimonial concept of I will administer
the oil reserves of Siberia but I will
also profit from them so
um so yeah a highly decentralized
Regional sort of governance wouldn't
really work for Russia either
so I think we have a problem here Esther
as to what sort of political system
would work for Russia well that leads me
into the next question from Carl which
is could you envision a scenario where
there is a breakup of Russia into
smaller States it's been for the same
reason no right I mean yes at the
fringes you could yeah especially if
they carry on mobilizing from from the
the
um you know so-called minorities like
dagee Sudan englishetti et cetera they
could be on the fringes Breakaway
movements but they don't see any
possibility of Russia being sort of
carved up into fiefdoms which is what
they thought of doing when they invaded
Russia in the 17th century or even in
the 19th century uh in Palmerston had
that idea
um and it's being mooted Now isn't it
that the problem of Russia is this big
Imperial aggressive power too big we
need to break it up yes who who Who's
the we who's going to break it up
conquering it I don't know but again the
problem is how can you have
small states with no resources
last question for you Orlando is um
one we hear a lot
um in different forms which is what do
you think will happen in Russia when
Putin dies and sort of Russia after
Putin has been a subject of speculation
for many years it's obviously
now people start to think well well
we've got Putin out the way could that
end the war or lead to some sort of
settlement who knows when Putin will no
longer be with us but but what how do
you see Russia's future with him gone
well it depends how much longer he's
around for I mean he might be forced out
before he dies
um but yeah if he lives say if I can't
see anything but a Putin Mark too and
perhaps worse after Putin because
especially if he goes while his war is
still on and I think the war is going to
go on for some time
um it's more likely he's replaced by a
very hard-line nationalist who wants to
take the war to the West uh then he's
replaced by someone looking for a
diplomatic solution
um
simply because for those for the regime
and those in power those are in around
the Inner Circle and indeed in the outer
circles to some extent it's an
existential battle
so
I'm afraid that
um
it's wishful thinking to to suppose that
Putin goes and they always breathe a
sigh of relief and say let's get in
someone more reasonable and and make
peace with the West I don't think that's
going to happen
it's been a fascinating discussion and
certainly a lot of insights into
how we got to this point that we're at
now so I'd like to thank Orlando's for a
fascinating conversation and um the book
again is the story of Russia
which you can see here uh or if you're
watching at least you can uh and you can
buy a copy from the books tab on the
right hand side of your screen or from
your local Bookshop now and it's in a
lot of book Bookshop Windows uh
certainly in this part of town of London
um I'm Josh glancy and you've been
watching or listening to intelligent
squared and thank you for doing so thank
you